I'm curious how your experiences in san
mateo have informed your perspective on
the education system specifically in the
u.s. so are there any practices or
innovations that have worked for you
that you think should or feasibly could
be applied in the US I hope that I hope
that there will be we worse it was so
hard for us to get the school going and
we had a local director we still have a
local director but we were so focused on
just going through the hoops that the
quality of education at the school is
really not so great and we haven't
learned anything yet but and the last
year we spent months rethinking about
reforming it and what we're trying now
and I think this would be we may learn
some things from this that could be
applicable to education here is that
we're doing project-based learning and
and the projects are to come from the
kit from the students and they should
have relevance to their life in san
mateo at them and so from the obvious
things seem to me like you know
deforesting how do how do we figure that
out what do we do about the garbage what
do we do about the polluted rivers blah
blah blah getting try and sustainable so
far they haven't come up with it was we
just started school just started three
weeks ago and so they're still kind of
learning this system but I hope so I am
NOT still ahead until this year haven't
really taught I taught this year I have
been teaching music and English so I'm
not an educator but I hope that we what
I think we will find is that education
should be local it should be determined
curriculum should be determined
according to the local circumstances and
I think there's a lot of need for that
here in the states especially like in an
inner city or own reservations or places
where people are marginalized or where
they live in it and a
polluted area you know you could find a
lot there's a lot that children can do
children student you know yeah adults
what I fits very exciting and what what
these children have that we don't well
you guys have it but but I see a lot of
teenagers in the states of the sort of
cynicism and about how the whole life is
so heavy and boring but they're just so
sparkly they're so sparkly and alive and
and it's it's really great love being
with the kids